[Music]
hi
this week I've decided to review the
naked a 3d body scanner that only works
if well you're naked
this full-length mirror from a company
named naked labs has a strip of 3d
cameras that capture a 360 degree image
of your body and different measurements
so you just stand right here and yeah no
but you know who doesn't mind being
naked in public in front of millions of
people this guy yes in the name of
journalism I recruited the naked cowboy
to help me test this very crazy very
creepy and somewhat cool mirror 3d
scanner with Johanna tanner okay here's
how this 1390 five-dollar mirror works
the Hat the guitar and the boots gotta
go the first step is to get as naked as
possible
you can go completely nude or you can
wear underwear on a bra you're gonna now
step on the scale now adjust your feet a
bit keep your head up put your arms to
your side I'm gonna hit this Scan button
in the app and you're off what's
happening now is the three intel
realsense cameras located on the side of
the mirror are capturing 3d data about
your body the scan takes about 15
seconds and then you wait during the
next two minutes or so the four
gigabytes of scanned data is processed
on the mirrors built-in computer then a
small file is sent to the cloud so you
can then see your scan and measurements
in the smartphone app and then BAM
there's this 3d clay-like image of your
body and you also get this possibly
horrifying list of measurements
you can compare results from one day to
the next so what do you make of all this
I think it looks really cool 23 pounds
of fat Jesus but just how accurate is
all this data one of the most accurate
ways to get your lean and fat mass
dunking in a mini jacuzzi
aka hydrostatic weighing so I found in
New York City gym to do the test I
dunked
held my breath for 10 seconds while the
computer calculated the results the
naked told me my body fat percentage was
25% the hydrostatic test said 37.8%
that's a pretty big difference the naked
circumference measurements however were
dead-on but who actually wants all this
information well people who want more
than just what an old-fashioned scale
would tell them despite working out and
dieting I've actually stopped losing
pounds and started toning and I've
noticed the difference in some of my
lower body scans over the last month but
that doesn't mean I like this thing
every time I step up here I feel uneasy
not because I'm uncomfortable with my
body but because I'm uncomfortable
giving a start-up access to my body
the company says right in its app that
it doesn't take photos just 3d depth
maps and everything kept on its servers
is encrypted and stored separately from
any personally identifiable information
still it's unsettling unless of course
we decide to live our lives like this
hero
[Music]